STEPHANIE: Introduce
our panel.
Don Dodge, Kevin Rose, Stacy
Brown-Philpot, and Chris Messina.
Can we get--
do you guys want to do just
a quick shout out for
introduction?
I'll pass it down the line.
Oh.
DON DODGE: Hello.
I'm Don Dodge from Google,
Microsoft, Alta Vista,
Napster, Groove Networks.
All kinds of companies, mostly
startups, except
for those first two.
So great to be here, and looking
forward to hear what
you have to tell us.
KEVIN ROSE: Hey, everybody.
I'm Kevin Rose from Google
Ventures, and I did Digg and
Milk and Pownce, and lots
of crazy things.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Hi, Stacy
Brown-Philpot, Entrepreneur in
Residence at Google Ventures,
and ran a bunch of teams at
Google to help launch products
that support a billion users.
CHRIS MESSINA: Howdy.
I'm Chris Messina.
I am a UX designer on Google+.
I did hashtags.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Without further ado, I'm going
to have Mark Cuban 2013.
MARK CUBAN: All right,
thank you.
America, we have a problem.
No one in this country knows
how to take ownership of
anything at all whatsoever.
So we, the gaming team here
tonight, went ahead and built
Cuban 2013, a real game where
you get to learn how to be an
NBA franchise owner and really
take ownership of something
that matters.
Being an NBA franchise
owner isn't easy.
You got billions of dollars,
multiple ex-spouses, deep,
complicated player
cap negotiations.
It's tough.
It's one of the hardest things
you could possibly do.
So we want to help teach
everybody how to Cubanize
themselves and really take
charge of their lives and
really learn how to manipulate
their friends and everyone
else into doing what
they want.
So in Cuban 2013, we use real
Google+ features to sort of
create an immersive strategy
game for everybody.
So, for instance, you can use
Google+ Hangouts to negotiate
under-handed trades, or cover
up players' scandals, like
when one of your players runs an
illegal dog fighting ring,
for instance.
Comes up, people.
Comes up.
This is real world stuff.
Or you can use Google Maps to go
and plan out your strategy
for having a local municipality
use taxpayer
dollars to fund your stadium,
while you simultaneously plan
to move to a city with a bigger
market at the same time.
These are real things
that come up.
And how are we going
to monetize?
A luxury tax, just like
the real NBA.
So we're Cuban 2013, and we're
here to Cubanize America for
the better.
Thank you very much.
Peace.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Fashion Roulette is up next,
but the judges, what do you
think of it?
DON DODGE: Major points
for humor.
Mark Cuban is quite the guy,
but I don't see much of a
business here, so no thanks.
KEVIN ROSE: I'm sold.
I'm totally going to invest.
It's amazing.
Thank you.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
I don't play games.
CHRIS MESSINA: Probably as
big as Farmville, so.
MALE SPEAKER: Mark Cuban
2013, nice job.
All right, Shopping Roulette.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, guys,
how's everybody doing tonight?
Who wants a deal?
All right.
So we are Shopping Roulette, a
chance for a deal risk free.
So what we are, we're a website
that liquidates
products for retailers.
So you come to our site, and you
pre-purchase, you purchase
and check out a brown bag.
You don't know what's
in this brown bag.
You start at different
price points.
So let's do a demo here.
We're going to start at
a $50 price point.
So I'm going to log
into my website.
I'm going to Google Checkout
or Wallet, and I'm going to
purchase a $50 brown bag.
I do not know what's in it.
So let's go.
All right.
What's my first choice?
I already have these.
I do not want these.
Next!
New products.
Oh, wow.
A camera, a better camera,
and a Chromebox.
I only spent $50.
This is a deal, but I
already have these.
Next.
Holy crap.
A TARDIS.
I want a TARDIS.
But I already have that, too.
Everybody has a TARDIS, right?
All right, next.
So that was my last choice.
So again, I spent $50.
So now I'm ready to cash out.
I didn't like my choices, so I'm
going to cash out with a
gift card from Starbucks,
Southwest Airlines, or Amazon.
My brother needs to fly
out here in San
Francisco in a month.
So I'm going to buy this
Southwest Airlines for $50.
Thank you very much,
Shop Roulette.
I just spent $50.
I had a choice of awesome
products.
I didn't like my choices.
I hit Next.
I didn't like those.
I ended up with the same value
of what I started with.
Shopping Roulette, a chance
for great deals risk free.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Up next, the health team, Last
Form, and then we've got the
education team Better Lecture.
Judges, take it away.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
I like it.
Creating a browsing experience
for shopping online.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah,
I love it, but I
wish it wasn't a website.
I wish it was an app.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN ROSE: It is pretty cool.
I like that it makes money.
I don't know that I would just
randomly bet $50 on something
and not know if I'm
going to get--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN ROSE: $1,000, I'm in.
Done deal.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DON DODGE: I like it a lot.
Make shopping fun, a little
gaming, a little gambling, a
little fun.
I like it a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right, the
health team, Last Form.
Take it away.
MARK: We're not getting--
OK.
My name is Mark, and
I'm not pregnant.
But I can't tell you
how many times--
that sounds like somebody who
wants to get me pregnant--
I can't tell you how many times
I've had to fill out a
form where I had to
tell somebody
that I'm not pregnant.
What I am is a patient.
I have four chronic diseases.
Those diseases are
private to me.
I want to keep it that way.
Security is a very big
deal in my life.
But every time I go to a doctor,
a specialist, or even
if I go to a massage therapist,
I still have to
fill out a form and tell them
about my health, about the
medications that I'm taking, and
all of the reasons why I'm
taking them.
I want to fill out
one last form.
And I'm going to introduce you
to Andrew, who works with
thousands of providers that are
actually already handing
these forms to patients like
you and me every day all
across the world.
He's got the ability, he's got
the skill, and he's got the
vision to drive this product
to be the next solution for
the medical industry.
Let me introduce Andrew.
ANDREW: Thanks a lot.
So here at Last Form, we are
here to disrupt stupidity.
You are still you, no matter
how many times you fill out
the same form.
You are still you.
A little background
about myself.
I've been in the health care
industry for the last 10
years, and this place is
ripe for disruption.
Everywhere you turn,
lots of problems.
Not only that, it's
a huge industry.
So at Last Form, what we are
really trying to do is connect
your information to whoever
you want to send it to.
We can use technologies like
Google's Virtual Machines,
NFC, Cloud Print, and take that
technology, give your
information to somebody else.
So we start small.
We're dreaming big.
And I have my first 1,000
customers already lined up.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you, Last Form.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So up next, we have education
team, Better Lecture, and then
we've got the government
team Marco Polo.
Judges, take it away
for Last Form.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
Good pain point.
It's a problem, a
huge problem.
I just don't like anything to do
with medical because all of
the regulations and insurance
and other crap.
But I like the idea but
it's a big pain point.
KEVIN ROSE: Yeah, on the web I
use 1Password and other types
of auto-fill services out there
to do a lot of this
heavy lifting or medium
lifting for me.
It's definitely a pain point.
I get it.
It makes sense.
I just don't know how you're
actually going to--
there's obviously a lot of devil
in the details, so I
don't know how you're
going to do it.
It sounds great up there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN ROSE: Yeah, I get it.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So
agree, big pain point.
I think people are still afraid
to put their medical
information online.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah, I mean,
I agree with these guys.
It's a huge problem, and I'm
wondering if you start with
young people or people that are
not so worried about it,
because this is something people
have been talking about
for a long time.
I want it real bad.
I don't know how you're
going to get there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Last Form.
Now we got Better Lecture.
MALE SPEAKER: Our company,
Better Lecture, is developing
a mobile app to help college
professors offer better
education by providing them with
an encouraging real time
student feedback.
In a large classroom setting,
oftentimes the students fall
behind and have questions.
The professors don't
even know about it.
Simply not practical for them to
stop every five seconds and
go, does everybody get it?
And even if they did, a lot of
the students would be too
intimidated to speak up.
So we're going to solve that
with a simple mobile app.
It allows the students to
provide the professor with
real time feedback using
this slider.
Green is I get it, move on.
Gray is I'm following along.
Red is I'm lost.
Please go back.
When they have questions, they
simply start typing it in.
We will aggregate the questions
the same way sites
like [INAUDIBLE] and Stack
Overflow do, and then submit
them to the teacher.
At that point, the professor
sets up his own alert system.
If 50% of the class is
lost, let me know.
If 12 people ask the same
question, let me know.
So that he knows
where to stop.
We like this idea because it'll
help students, prevent
students from falling behind,
and will help professors
improve their lectures
and their class.
And for administrators, who
are probably going to be
paying the bill here, we'll
help them evaluate teacher
performance.
[APPLAUSE]
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Really
like this, having gone to
school with lots of people in
the room and big classes.
Who pays for it?
That's what I wonder.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah, I agree.
I think this is great.
I think having this kind of
immediate feedback would be
really awesome.
And I think the more that you
do to help teachers to
actually make use of this
information, as opposed to
just leaving it up to them to
figure it out, would make this
really valuable.
KEVIN ROSE: Yep, I agree.
I love the problem, and it
sounds like you have a good
solution for it.
I just don't know how
big the business is.
With all the schools in, say,
you take the United States, is
that a billion dollar company?
Probably not, but it's
a great idea.
DON DODGE: Yep, I
like it a lot.
A good pain point.
Problem is, there are two things
that I refuse to invest
in, education and health care.
[BOOING]
DON DODGE: I know.
The reason is because--
it's the same reason.
It's education and health
care are too structured.
They don't respond to natural
market forces.
They're dominated by regulation,
government
regulation and unions.
So it's so difficult to make
money in that space.
But I agree.
It's a problem, and I
like the idea a lot.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
All right.
Up next, we got Marco Polo.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Better?
There we go.
All right.
So the first time I went
overseas, I wanted to study
abroad in Barcelona.
And one of the first individuals
that I met was
this nice Italian kid.
And then we got to talking.
He spoke a little bit
of broken Spanish.
I spoke a little bit
of broken Italian.
And we got to mingling.
And like any other American,
at the end of the
conversation, I went for a high
five, and I stuck my hand
up like this.
He looked at me, stuck
his hand up, and
then petted my face.
It was very awkward,
to say the least.
But as a person that's traveled
a lot since, I've
realized that as Americans, we
have a lot to learn about
going overseas in terms of
nuances, cultural things, and
how to interact with the
local population.
So at Marco Polo, we aim to make
travelling less awkward
by offering you information
from real people in real
countries that teach you how to
interact, how to cooperate,
and how to learn from
those around you.
So that's what we aim to do.
We aim to make you travel
like a native.
And so you're probably asking
yourself, how do you monetize?
How do you turn this
thing around?
And our plan is by offering
different sorts of content.
Level one, you're
going to China.
So what do you have?
You have a travel list,
and that's about it.
A different level, now you have
more specific information
on the region that you're
traveling to.
And our target market, of
course, is the new traveler
because there's people going
everywhere nowadays, and the
world's becoming smaller.
So what we aim to do is to
make it easier and more
streamlined by making it less
awkward so you don't get
patted by nice Italian
gentlemen.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Marco Polo.
Up next, we have Venuize
and then Smart Diction.
All right.
Judges, take it away.
DON DODGE: Travel is a
huge market, so lots
of money spent there.
So that's great.
It's an interesting problem.
I'd like to see it be mobile,
and maybe you could do the web
as free, but mobile as paid.
So when they're traveling, they
want the mobile version.
When they're planning the
travel, they do it
for free on the web.
I like the idea.
It's good.
KEVIN ROSE: I also like
the idea a lot.
I think the name's great.
I think that any time there is
intent around something,
especially wanting to travel,
there's ways to monetize it,
so I wouldn't be too concerned
about that.
Yeah, it makes sense to me.
Anytime you go to someplace new,
you don't want to stick
out like a sore thumb.
And I would use your service.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
I like it.
I worry it becomes a blog.
So I would try to get something
where it's real time.
So if I'm in the moment, and I
put my hand up, tell me don't
ever put your hand up
when you're in Rome.
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean,
I don't see anything
wrong with being petted.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS MESSINA: So I like it.
I think if you figure out some
way of helping out the folks
who are actually providing the
information, giving them a
reason to get together to talk
to share this stuff, that
might also be an interesting
way of adding
value for them as well.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Where
is Venuize?
MALE SPEAKER: Can everyone
hear me?
AUDIENCE: No.
MALE SPEAKER: How about now?
MALE SPEAKER: Is it on?
Oh, sick.
All right, cool.
All right.
I'm here to talk
about Venuize.
It's Google Analytics for
professional event organizers.
So professional event organizers
worldwide spend
marketing money, effort, time,
and resources to push out
their event and try to get
attendees to come to their
event, but they have no way
of measuring the success.
So for example, I come
to this event today.
Great event.
Great job by the organizer.
I look at the table.
There's a bunch of name
tags left over.
As the organizer, I
want to know, who
referred those people?
Which affiliate referred
those people?
Maybe they signed up on a
specific page on a social
network, and I want to take that
information and optimize
for my future events.
Now, imagine that
scenario today.
Times it by 1.8 million
professional events across the
US during one year.
This is a billion
dollar industry.
And our solution lets them track
the conversion rate of
each medium from which guests
register, track which guests
have the highest attendance
rate, have the highest
loyalty, spend the most amount
of money, which affiliates are
most useful.
And the technology we'll use
will obviously be integrated
with Google+ events, and
check-ins will be done on
Android tablets and phones.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Venuize.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Up next, we
have Smart Diction,
and then Shop TV.
Judges, take it away.
CHRIS MESSINA: It's good.
I mean, you've got some heavy
competition coming from
Eventbrite and other guys like
that, but I work on Google+,
so I'm happy to see the first
events integration.
So right on.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: OK.
So I, too, like the events
integration.
I worry that this isn't
a big enough problem.
I think the bigger problem is
organizing how people enter,
sign up, check in to events
when they get there,
especially when it's a lot
of people at them.
And I would think about how to
build that into your idea.
KEVIN ROSE: I like consumer
internet stuff, so this is a
little boring for me.
I think it's a good idea.
It's just not in my personal
wheelhouse, but I think that
most of the events that I've
gone to, there's absolutely no
tracking around the different
problems that
you outlined here.
So to have some tracking and
some visibility into really
what's going on makes complete
sense to me.
I think it would work.
DON DODGE: It's a big market.
A lot of companies have tried
to solve this problem of
building a community that lasts
beyond the event, and
that kind of thing.
I haven't seen a single one
succeed yet, but somebody's
going to do it.
And I like what you're doing.
MALE SPEAKER: Why do you
think they haven't
been able to succeed?
DON DODGE: I don't know.
There's been a lot of companies
try, and a lot of
money spent trying to do it.
I don't know why they failed,
but I haven't seen a single
one succeed yet.
So hopefully you'll do it.
MALE SPEAKER: Good feedback.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Smart Diction,
where are you guys?
All right.
Somebody want to drive
the slides?
Yep, right there.
NICK: [INAUDIBLE].
Hi, my name is Nick, and
I'm with Smart Diction.
Have you ever gone to a
location, maybe an event, like
Google I/O, and tried to type
something to your friend and
let them know you're at Google
I/O. What your phone does is
fight against you.
Maybe you're in--
AUDIENCE: Louder!
Can't hear!
NICK: [INAUDIBLE]
Hello?
Hi, my name is Nick, and
I'm with Smart Diction.
Have you guys ever been to a
location, and you're trying to
tell somebody that you
know where you're at?
Maybe you're at Disneyland, and
you're trying to tell your
kids to come meet you.
But no, you get something
else.
Have you ever gone to an event,
and you're trying to
type into your phone something
about the event you're at?
Maybe a hashtag, or maybe the
restaurant you're going to.
Or you want to be at Google I/O.
But the dictionary says
that's not a word.
Well, Smart Diction
can fix that.
What we do is we take geographic
data about where
you're located, as well as the
people you're with, through
your social graph and your
social networks, you're
tweeting, your Four
Squares, your
Twitters, your Google Places.
And we take this information,
and we combine it into your
dictionary in an intelligent
manner.
So what we can do is say
you're trying to add a
hashtag, and you don't really
know exactly how
to spell that hashtag.
Well, what we can do is we can
actually realize other people
in the area that are tweeting,
and we can include that in
your dictionary for you.
Now, this is something that a
lot of different people are
trying to solve in many
different ways.
We've seen companies like Swype
and SlideIT and Siri
that have all tried to
enter this space.
And they're doing it
in different ways.
We do it in a unique
way through
geography and social context.
This is something that people
like carriers, OEMs, and even
large companies like Google and
Apple are interested in.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Shop TV and
Connect In on deck, please.
Judges, take it away.
DON DODGE: I like this.
Hello hello?
Hello?
Ah, yes.
All right.
I like this idea a lot.
I was the first investor in
Swype, and I made a lot of
money on that.
So I like this idea.
And Swype and all the others are
not approaching it the way
that you're doing it.
So I think this is a feature,
and it's a feature that would
be acquired by one of
these big companies,
but I like it a lot.
KEVIN ROSE: Yeah, I agree.
It sounds like a feature.
It's not really a business.
I mean, I'm not going to pay
to have Smart Diction on my
phone, obviously.
And someone will just
buy this up for--
I don't know that it's going to
be a $100 or $200 million
exit for you, but it
could be something.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Love it.
I've been wanting a good
dictionary on my phone, and so
please go and build this.
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean, if you
can help people be smarter
about hashtags, then
hell yeah.
Like, maybe tell them
not to use them if
they're over doing it.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Now we got Shop TV.
JEFF DANIELY: All right, I'm
Jeff Daniely with Shop TV, and
some related question, how many
people in here watch TV?
Yeah?
One or two of you, a few.
So guess what?
So the TV business model has
not changed in 60 years.
It's freaking lame.
So what we're doing is we're
going to work with
internet-connected TVs, such as
TVs that are enabled with
Google TV, and we're also going
to launch a companion
application that lets people
interact with those TVs while
they are watching TV.
So what kind of TV are
they watching?
It's VOD.
It's something they DVRed.
It's live TV.
It's Hulu.
It's Netflix.
It doesn't really
matter to us.
What we're going to do is we're
going to use existing
technologies, just like what you
see on TV today when you
see a commercial that has
a Shazam tag, right?
And the Shazam example
sucks, right?
Because you get out your phone
and go through all this
process, right?
And tag the commercial.
What we're going to do is have
an application running in the
background on your Google TV
device that then identifies
what you're watching, where
you're at in the program, and
what's on the screen at
that time, right?
And then what-- yes,
bless you.
And what you can do at
that time is purchase
what you see on TV.
So let's say my wife is watching
Desperate Housewives,
and Eva Longoria walks across
the beach, and she's got these
great sandals.
And my wife's like, oh my god,
I want those sandals.
So she can take out her phone
or use a remote control and
tag what she sees on TV at
that time, and buy it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
We got Connect In.
ALEX: Actually, it's
Connect-on.
MALE SPEAKER: Hold on.
Hold on.
We still have judges.
Where'd you go?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah,
whatever questions
you have, fire away.
CHRIS MESSINA: So I think it's
an interesting opportunity.
I wonder if there's
actually intent.
If someone's actually watching
something, I think the last
thing they want to do is
think about losing
money, spending on things.
So I'm wondering how you
actually bridge the gap
between being entertained
versus
actually paying for something.
JEFF DANIELY: So we did take
the time tonight to talk to
several members of the audience
to talk about the
need and desire to see something
on TV and say, oh,
you know what?
That's great.
That's a red carpet dress that I
want, or the shoes on TV, or
whatever it might be.
But people see that, and they
just kind of file that away,
and say, well, yeah that's
interesting.
And if they're prompted sometime
in the future, then
they might engage in that.
But if we can present an
opportunity on the screen and
let the user tag it--
and this can be totally
unobtrusive, right?
So this can be as simple as
like adding it to your
shopping cart.
Bam.
Oh, yeah, I want that.
And I'll come back
to it later.
Or maybe my wife missed it, and
she wants to come back to
it later and say, I really
like those shoes.
But I want to buy those.
So she can come back to it
later in time, and scroll
through and see, those are the
shoes that I want, and I want
to buy that.
CHRIS MESSINA: So like a Read
It Later for TV ads.
JEFF DANIELY: Exactly.
Because hey, guess what?
When people watch TV today,
what happens when
they see the ads?
Fast forward.
They don't watch
the ads, right?
So it's all about product
placement.
And there are companies today
that specialize in placing
products in television shows,
but they have no way to
measure what happens when they
put that Lotus, a car, in the
television show.
CHRIS MESSINA: So that seems
like that's actually your
better opportunity, is to figure
out how to buy the
things in the show as
you're watching it.
JEFF DANIELY: That's part of the
business model, is to work
with the product placement--
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
thank you.
We've gone way over.
JEFF DANIELY: I'm
here all night.
All right.
MALE SPEAKER: We
got Connect-on.
KEVIN ROSE: I just want
to say real quick--
MALE SPEAKER: You've
got good questions.
KEVIN ROSE: I skipped
you, but--
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
I like it.
What he just said was a real
opportunity is the real
opportunity.
You've got to create the
wish list that people
can buy right there.
JEFF DANIELY: And that's
what it is.
It's the wish list.
It's the add to your
cart, [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN ROSE: All right,
let's keep going.
So I love this idea.
I think it's awesome.
I think like one click checkout
for the TV is amazing.
I've wanted several of the
swords in Game of Thrones, so
if you can make that
happen, done deal.
DON DODGE: Great idea.
JEFF DANIELY: Note to self.
DON DODGE: Go for it.
JEFF DANIELY: Shop TV, people.
Thank you.
ALEX: So hi.
My name is Alex.
I'm 22.
I'm a young, French
entrepreneur.
So when I arrive here, I
heard about this guy.
I think it's Kevin, Kevin
Rose or something.
Someone told me he was famous.
So basically I thought
you might be
interested in my idea.
So I started looking for
connections, and--
KEVIN ROSE: Stalking.
ALEX: And just a way
to get introduced.
And so I went on Facebook, and
we had no common friends.
I went on Google+, and we had
no common connections.
And then also LinkedIn.
But actually, there
was a connection.
I just didn't know
it was there.
And Connect-on helped
me find it.
So basically, the connection
was that this guy, Ken, is
actually connected to
Kevin on Google+.
And we are friends
on Facebook.
So there is a link.
But I just didn't know
it was there.
So basically, Connect-on is
about finding and discovering
the missing connection.
That's it.
MALE SPEAKER: So we have
Music Bacon, and then
Teen Lock on deck.
Go ahead, judges.
DON DODGE: Yeah, interesting
idea.
The problem is putting these
social networks together.
There were some barriers
there that some of
them don't want breached.
But I think it's an
interesting idea.
Good luck.
ALEX: Thank you.
KEVIN ROSE: How's it going?
ALEX: Good.
KEVIN ROSE: It's a little
awkward now.
ALEX: I know, but at least there
is a connection, right?
KEVIN ROSE: So we could just go
have a beer afterwards or
something, and you don't
have to build the app.
You can just--
ALEX: It's just a pre-text.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: How do you
break down the barriers?
There's a lot of contacts in
email that go beyond just your
social connections.
How do you do that?
ALEX: Yeah.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: If you
can't do that, there's no idea
here to me.
ALEX: So here's the
interesting part.
We haven't really figured out.
But actually, this guy does.
MALE SPEAKER: So part of what
we'd want to do is, there's
the connections that are the
private connections you have
to authenticate with, where you
have to go in and sign in
with your Twitter, Facebook,
whatever.
But there's also the connections
that you can get
from the public social graph.
So if someone's not logged in,
we can start with there.
So if someone's tweeting at
Kevin Rose or whatever, we can
start to pull that in to bring
the connections together to
figure out how these
people are related.
And that's cross barriers.
You can go and you could search
the public timeline for
Twitter, for Facebook,
for Google+.
You can start there, and then
once people connect their
accounts, you have that more
powerful information.
So that's how we can start
to reach through that.
And I think there's
some way to bring
hashtags into that, too.
[LAUGHTER]
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
[INAUDIBLE].
ALEX: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS MESSINA: No bonus
points for that one.
MALE SPEAKER: Worh a shot.
Worth a shot.
CHRIS MESSINA: So
I like the idea.
I think there's been some other
folks who have tried to
do this recently.
There's like Banjo, and
Highlight, and Sonar, and a
bunch of those folks.
I think the real problem is
actually getting the high
quality suggestions and
recommendations.
I also think the other problem
is actually coming up with the
right context to make
those introductions.
So you're just as well starting
a bar as creating
this app, and you might
find you make more
connections that way.
So you can try that too.
ALEX: Of course.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thanks, guys.
ALEX: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: We
got some Bacon.
DAVID: Test.
OK.
My name is David, and my
idea is Music Bacon.
Music Bacon is a ticketing
system that rewards fans with
free tickets for inviting
their friends to
also come to a concert.
So this is a huge market, $15
billion are done annually in
ticketing sales in the United
States, and this
is a growing market.
So the problem is that 40% of
tickets go unsold in the
United States.
And most people want to
go to more shows.
They just don't know about it.
So how does this work?
So I buy a ticket online,
or let's say Chris
buys a ticket online.
So he shares that.
He gets a referral code.
Shares that to his friends.
When each of his friends buys
a ticket, they get 20% off.
So if you invite five
friends, you get a
completely free ticket.
So why would venues ever
jump for this thing?
Well, 40% of tickets
go unsold, right?
And most of their revenue comes
from beer, not actually
from tickets.
It's in their interest to sell
out every single show.
So you can't talk about this
without competitors, right?
There's tons of ticketing
competitors, the largest
being, obviously,
Ticketmaster.
Everyone hates Ticketmaster.
In the industry, they are
called Ticketbastards.
And they're one of the top five
e-commerce websites on
the internet, and probably
one of the
worst e-commerce websites.
So for instance--
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So we have Teen
Lock and then Ability and that
wraps us up.
Judges, go ahead.
CHRIS MESSINA: So I think this
is an interesting idea.
It's a sort of play on the
Groupon, Living Social thing
that's happening now.
I think obviously getting your
friends to go to a concert
with you makes a lot of sense.
And that's interesting.
I think the biggest challenge,
actually, is probably breaking
into this, driving awareness,
building relationships, like
all that stuff.
So I didn't hear you talk too
much about technology.
I heard sort of like referral
code thing going on.
So like, what is it that
you're really building?
DAVID: So web site first,
mobile second.
But I'm a mobile developer,
killer mobile app.
CHRIS MESSINA: OK.
OK.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
I'm not sure.
I don't know how you get
people to switch.
We all, for various reasons,
don't like Ticketmaster, but
what else do you do besides go
into Times Square, and put the
little ticket booth up that
you can go to and get
discounted tickets?
DAVID: First customer
is venues.
Venues have to buy in
for the tickets.
DAVID: It sounds complicated.
KEVIN ROSE: So you get bonus
points for the best logo of
the night, I think.
The bacon was pretty awesome.
You might want to have a soy
option for the vegetarian
people out there.
I'm curious though if--
60% of shows go unsold,
or 40%?
DAVID: 40% go unsold.
KEVIN ROSE: 40% go unsold.
So how does--
let's say there's the White
Stripes or some kind of crazy
band playing.
It's going to sell
out immediately.
Like, do you get
them on board?
Or does that just--
DAVID: So we would have other
tickets, too, non-Bacon
tickets, they're called
vegan tickets.
KEVIN ROSE: Gotcha.
I was just wondering because it
seems to me that the reason
that 40% of shows go unsold
is because those
bands are not really--
they kind of suck.
DAVID: Awareness for the 60%.
KEVIN ROSE: It would just be
hard to get five of my friends
to go see a really
crappy band.
DON DODGE: I think you want to
focus on the non-Ticketmaster,
non-A list things.
DAVID: Start at the bottom.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
Ticketmaster has a stranglehold
on these things
because they have contracts
that can't be broken.
But I think there is a big
opportunity for the other 50%
of the music market that is not
controlled by Ticketmaster
and is not controlled by the big
venues, and this could be
a pretty interesting idea.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Nice work.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: We
got Teen Lock.
MALE SPEAKER: Is this on?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Texting and
driving is killing teens.
In 2010, 416,000 people were
injured in a distracted driver
related crash.
48% of teens say that they've
been in a car where the driver
was texting.
Parents need a way to know that
their teen cannot drive
while they're texting.
Our company will manufacture
Teen Lock, a system that
prevents teens texting
and driving.
The system is made of a hardware
ignition lock, an
app, and an NFC tag.
The teen must touch their phone
to the NFC tag before
their car can start.
The phone is switched by the
Teen Lock into guardian mode,
and will not leave that mode
until the car is shut off.
The system will work
in any car.
The system works on Android
NFC-enabled devices.
The phone is still available
for the driver to use or
anybody to use in
an emergency.
We sell the parents and the
guardians of teen drivers.
We sell Teen Lock through the
standard retail outlets for
cell phones, such as car stereo
installers, Best Buy,
Amazon, Verizon,
Sprint stores.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Last team,
Ability, please get on deck.
Judges, take it away.
DON DODGE: This is
a great idea.
I have a friend, a personal
friend, who's doing something
similar called ZoomSafer.
It's a terrific idea.
He's using GPS, and that
kind of thing.
So this might be a
better approach.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
We're trying to find a way
that's not circumventable.
KEVIN ROSE: I like the idea.
It could save lives.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Agree.
Selling to parents is good.
I also think that rallying local
police departments is
another way to get the
awareness out.
KEVIN ROSE: Sorry.
I think you could definitely
get a discount on car
insurance for the people
to install it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Excellent.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Yeah.
Insurance companies,
lots of partnership
opportunities there.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah, I agree.
I think this is great.
I think also finding possible
car manufacturers that are
interested in this kind of
thing, more forward-looking
car manufacturers that are
interested in providing these
kind of controls.
Even like for anti-theft
or things like that
could be very useful.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
OEMs, especially automotive
OEMs, are a tough mountain to
climb, so we'd want
to start in the
aftermarket and then go there.
And there's already ignition
interlock devices for
different purposes
like billing,
car billing and stuff.
So the technology is hardened.
And as a matter of fact, my
wife and I had a contract
manufacturing company,
and we actually built
devices like that.
So this is there.
CHRIS MESSINA: Cool.
Great.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So we got Ability now.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Did you
understand that?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, this is a
problem with 18 million people
worldwide who use sign
language and
still can not go--
able to say as clear words and
their own feelings to the
people, even to their family.
Because we take it for granted
they do texting.
They learn the communicating
with the world.
But it's not a problem.
I learned the sign language,
but I didn't use
it for three months.
And when I went to the school,
to the people who were doing
sign language, I couldn't
do it perfectly well.
So it was very troublesome.
The problem we're trying to
solve here is communication.
The idea is, when you do the
sign language, when the people
do the sign language, mobile
will capture the sign
language real time.
Google Glass can be one
of the example.
And convert into
text and voice.
We have already used voice to
text sign language, which is
working perfectly.
One way to communicate with them
to tell them what we are
trying to say to them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's a gestural
interface for
communicating with mobile
devices, like Google Glasses,
using Leap Motion.
It teaches you American Sign
Language, which is a language
that 80 million people already
speak, enabling you to
communicate with these people.
And it's as simple as
learning a new touch
gesture for your phone.
This language already has an
established lexicon of
intuitive gestures like take
a picture, or [INAUDIBLE].
It's that easy.
And it's sort of like a sneaky
Rosetta Stone for American
Sign Language.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean, it seems
like an amazing idea if
you can bridge the sign language
verbal, spoken
communication divide.
I think getting it to work
really well and making it
available to lots and lots
of people I think is
probably the challenge.
But if you can make it
work sufficiently
well, that's great.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So I
have an 11 month-old.
We're trying to teach her
baby sign language.
So if this can help
me, I'm in.
MALE SPEAKER: Here you go.
KEVIN ROSE: I think this is a
great play in with Google
Glass, so I'm excited to
see you take it there.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you very
much for the encouragement.
DON DODGE: This is a huge
problem for a small number of
people who would probably pay
a lot of money to solve it.
And it's a noble cause,
a great idea.
Go for it.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So you guys all did
an amazing job.
I'm going to take the judges
back to deliberate.
Frank from Startup Weekend, can
you come up here and talk
a little bit about
entrepreneurship?
You guys all deserve a
round of applause.
You guys are awesome.
Keep them entertained, Frank.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Remember,
Shopping Roulette is a
trillion-dollar industry.
FRANK: Hey guys.
STEPHANIE: Oh wait, Frank.
Real quick.
Sorry.
So I just found out
[INAUDIBLE]
video releases.
So I've been giving them to some
of the speakers, but a
couple of first people
who went missed it.
So if you didn't get a video
release, please come see me.
Thank you.
FRANK: All right.
Hey guys, my name is Frank.
I'm French.
So first of all, I'm just going
to test if you guys can
understand me.
So if you understand me, can
you clap your hands?
One time.
Or two times, three times.
That's good.
Real quick.
I don't want to take too
much of your time.
Everybody here must
be exhausted.
This was an experiment for us.
I know it wasn't easy
for everybody.
I hope you guys had
a good time.
Did you guys have a good
time, by the way?
[APPLAUSE]
FRANK: OK.
Just to keep in mind maybe why
we do that at Startup Weekend,
and just give you a little
bit of background
about what's our mission.
So Startup Weekend, you guys
are here in San Francisco.
So you're kind of spoiled.
You're surrounded by
entrepreneurs, by people who
wake up in the morning doing
all these things, but we've
got Startup Weekend now,
I think, running in 105
countries, and in more
than 300 cities.
Some of them being in
Mongolia or Egypt.
We had people running Startup
Weekend during the
revolution in Egypt.
So you know you're spoiled.
You know it's not
easy [INAUDIBLE]
right?
Entrepreneurship is something
we try to understand.
And I'd like to just give you
an example, which I think
gives you some perspective
on entrepreneurship.
Everybody knows the game
of chess, right?
And when you play chess, you've
got two players, an
eight-by-eight grid,
a couple of moves.
But the number of combinations
you've got is 10 to
the power of 123.
That's how complex you can get
with something as easy as a
board and two players.
So when you guys play the game
of entrepreneurship, you're
playing against seven billion
people with a lot of rules,
most of them being unknown.
This is like volunteering
for the Hunger Games.
So congratulations
for you guys.
You guys are crazy.
I hope you have a good time.
I'm going to put some music.
We're going to scream
whenever the judges
are going to be back.
Stephanie, do you want
to say a few words?
Stephanie from Google, if you
can give her a big round of
applause because the girl right
here is the one who put
everything together.
Ahmed too is going to be back.
[INAUDIBLE] applause for you.
I love to talk during hours,
but as we said, [INAUDIBLE]
collection.
I'm learning more from you guys
than you can learn from
me speaking.
So congratulations.
By the way, who learned
something here today?
That's good.
Thank you very much.
STEPHANIE: Actually, I want
to throw it back to Frank.
And actually, Ahmed and Connor
did a lot of this planning.
So I'm really happy and
thrilled to see
all you guys here.
I like to say, every time, every
event, no matter how
many events I do, I'm just
like a high school girl.
I'm afraid either oh my god, no
one's going to come to my
party, or oh my god, too many
people are going to come, and
they're going to trash
my parents' house.
So you guys are right
in the middle.
So you guys are perfect.
Thank you so much.
Also wanted to--
wait.
Where--
I guess, oh he's with
the judges.
That's right.
OK.
But actually, I just want to
do a little straw poll.
Where did you guys come from?
How many people came
through the--
how many people are
going to I/O?
Yes.
Ah.
Nice.
How many people are
in the local
Startup Weekend community?
Yeah.
Right on.
How many people are the local
Google developer group?
All right.
OK, OK, good job.
Awesome.
So I'm really happy to see a
good mix of people here.
And I hope that you guys take
this experience back to your
home cities or if you're
local and spread this
entrepreneurial spirit.
That's really great.
How many people think you're
going to actually try to
pursue this idea?
OK.
OK, very nice.
Very exciting.
All right.
OK, so we have, I think, some
more-- so who's hungry?
Is anyone still hungry?
Anyone got the munchies?
A little bit?
OK.
All right.
So let's mingle amongst
ourselves for a few minutes.
I'll grab some pizza and see
if anybody wants some.
All right?
Cool.
I'll be right back.
Oh, one quick update.
I didn't mention this earlier,
but Kevin hadn't responded to
my request for one-on-one mentor
time for the winners,
but he just agreed to do it.
So not only do you get Chris
Messina, Don Dodge, and Stacy
for mentor time.
You get one-on-one time
with Kevin Rose.
So just FYI, keep
that in mind.
It'll be part of the
prize package.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, everybody.
If we can have a seat
really quick.
We have some announcements.
The moment of truth.
So I hope you guys
had a good time.
I know it's already
11 o'clock.
Again, this isn't about
winning or losing.
It's about having a good
time, learning
through actually doing.
And I hope you guys enjoyed
this experience.
I know that for the full Startup
Weekend experience,
it's an awesome experience.
And the next event that we're
actually going to be having is
in July in San Francisco.
And I'm sure a lot of you guys
are not from here, so just be
sure to check your
city's sites.
We've got events all
over the world.
So make sure to join one, if
you enjoyed this, and tell
your friends.
But the judges have a verdict.
And take it away, Kevin.
Oh, thanks to the judges.
You guys are awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN ROSE: So thanks for
having us here tonight.
Done just whispered in my ear
that just for a few hours of
work, this is some pretty
impressive stuff.
And so we're all really
impressed.
The highest score we could give
you was a 15, and I had
several companies in
double digits.
So lots of good stuff here.
The winner of the competition.
Cuban 2013 was not the winner,
but a great startup.
The winner is Teen Lock.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN ROSE: Congrats.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: You know what?
we came up with this
idea two hours ago.
KEVIN ROSE: And I think we're
going to announce our
favorite runner up.
Every judge has their favorite
that was not the winner.
So as far as runners up.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So my
runners up, Shopping Roulette.
I really like the
browsing online.
I really like that experience.
Fun, interactive.
Good, good.
And then Better Lecture, really
redefining the way
feedback happens in
the classroom.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah, so I also
had Better Lecture on there.
I thought you guys had a good
idea, and I think education is
ripe for disruption.
I really also like Smarter
Diction, or
Smart Diction, I guess.
Again, anything that can help
people do better at hashtags
makes me happy.
And I also liked Ability, which
I'm also expecting will
have air hashtags supported
in its first release.
So I like that.
KEVIN ROSE: So I thought that
in-ad and product placement on
televisions, Apple is going
to do it with Apple TV, so
someone should do
for Google TV.
And I think Shop TV, I think
it's a great idea.
And my next one was
Better Lecture.
DON DODGE: Mark Cuban is a
personal friend of mine, and
if you got serious about this,
he would probably fund you.
That was funny, but
it wasn't serious.
So reconsider.
My number one was Teen Lock.
I have a friend who's doing
something like this.
It's a great business.
I think you'll be successful.
My number two was Smart Diction,
but I'm probably
biased because of
the Swype thing.
I think it's a great feature,
and I think you could have a
quick exit and make
some money there.
My third one was Shopping
Roulette.
[APPLAUSE]
DON DODGE: I love the idea.
Shopping, making shopping fun
and a game and a little bit of
gambling, and all good things.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
That's it, folks.
Thanks again for coming.
You guys are awesome.
Give it up for yourselves.
And a big thanks to all the
volunteers that put this on.
Google, you guys are awesome.
Thanks, everybody.
And there's a bunch of parties
still going on, so make sure
to party it up.
We'll see you at I/O if you are
at I/O, and thanks again.
Drive safe.